material slowdown in growth notable
increase inflation that's the NPC's
judgment it's a judgment not based on it
is a judgment not based on a whim it's a
judgment based on rigorous analysis and
careful consideration and it is the
judgment of the independent MP scene is
the judgment of all members of the MTC
I'll make that very clear now of course
there's a range of possible scenarios
around those directions which could
possibly include a technical recession
could possibly include that we haven't
done a formal forecast the thing that I
would stress again what's important here
from our perspective is to provide
information provide perspective not just
about the major risks to our central
forecast but what it might mean for
monetary policy and what are the
considerations for the stance of
monetary policy because what we don't
want to do wouldn't want to do which
wouldn't be fair to the British people
or or would be to pop up at the start of
July and say oh by the way this is what
we think is what we thought then about
the situation now so this is our best
perspective I would stress though that
our perspectives both in terms of the
central forecast conditioned on remain
and our perspectives around risks extend
out to the monetary policy horizon it's
entirely within our remit it's that our
agreement is two to three years we're
not making a judgment we're not making a
forecast I know you notice but it's
important to stress it we're not making
a judgment or forecaster an assessment
of the longer-term economic consequences
of either decision nor will we make that
determination but we have a
responsibility under our remit it is
explicitly in statute and in our remit
to talk about the risks and the
trade-offs that monetary policy faces so
that the British people can better
understand the potential paths of
monetary policy because it's the one
thing we all know is that the path of
the economy the shock so that can hit an
economy are uncertain and and it's
better if
people can anticipate how the bank
specifically the MPC would respond if
those uncertainties come come to pass